[Musik]
meine lieben freunde noch nie haben sich
so viele menschen derart intensiv und in
echtzeit mit einer krankheit beschäftigt
die im fall des corona wuchs die
apokalyptische art und weise in der
politik medien und auch viele normale
menschen mit dem thema cupid 19 umgehen
erweckt den anschein als ob es nicht
auch eine epidemiologische singularität
handeln würde eine in der
menschheitsgeschichte noch nie
dagewesene herausforderung
wenn wir jedoch in die geschichte
zurückblicken sieht das ganz anders aus
im laufe vieler jahre tausende war die
menschheit mit so viel wie dem ihnen
konfrontiert dass man quasi sagen kann
der umgang mit ihnen liege eigentlich in
der natur des menschen in der tat war
der umgang mit epidemien früher
alltäglich und wurde als gottgegeben
angesehen lasst uns also einen kurzen
blick in die geschichte werfen um die
größten gesundheits krisen zu
analysieren welche unsere vorfahren
überstehen mussten
denn nur wenn wir ihre geschichte kennen
können wir die bedeutung von epidemien
und pandemien richtig einordnen und
alles kann ich dir schon jetzt verraten
ihr einfluss ist gewaltig denn diese
welt und die heutige zivilisation wurden
in extrem großem maße durch krankheiten
geformt und willst du wissen die genau
beachten dann lasst uns sofort anfangen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lasst mich bitte eines klarstellen die
größten killer von menschen sind und
waren nicht der mensch sondern
mikroorganismen die erreger von pocken
masern grippe malaria tuberkulose und co
diese krankheiten können als die größten
mörder aller zeiten angesehen werden
aber auch als große soziale architekten
ohne die unsere welt heute ganz anders
aussehen würde und wie genau das
verraten wir die in diesem video
die schwarze pest
wie würde wohl europa aussehen wenn es
im vierzehnten jahrhundert nicht durch
den schwarzen tod verwüstet von wäre die
damalige pest epidemie gilt als die
tödlichste in der geschichte der
menschheit um ihre auswirkungen zu
verstehen müssen wir uns
vergegenwärtigen dass gegen ende des
dreizehnten jahrhundert europa einen
aufschwung erlebt werden die handelswege
mit asien ist auf grund der barbaren
zerschnitten worden waren wird dann die
dazu funktionieren neben einer
florierenden wirtschaft entstand jedoch
auch das was der historiker natori einen
gemeinsamen markt für mikroben
bezeichnet mit den waren und händlern
kam auch neue krankheiten gegen die der
noch keine immunität besaßen die pest
brachten wohl im jahr 1347 mäuse und
ratten auf schiffen aus china in
italienische kino
von dort breitete sie sich über den
ganzen kontinent aus und rafft innerhalb
von fünf jahren einen großen teil der
europäischen bevölkerung dahin einige
schätzungen zufolge stadt fast die
hälfte der menschen europas an schwarzen
tod der historiker karl pohler schätzt
dass an der pest zwischen 350 und 351
also innerhalb von drei jahren 25
millionen menschen starben bei einer
gesamtbevölkerung europas von damals
gerade mal 80 millionen
[Musik]
diese pandemie hatte zur folge dass ist
mehrere jahrhunderte dauerte bis europa
wieder die alte bevölkerungsdichte
erreicht hatte der schock steckte so
tief dass auch nach abklingen der
eigentliche test die bevölkerungszahl
des kontinents noch bis ins jahr 1460
also ganz ab 100 jahre später weiter
abnahm und erst dann wieder allmählich
anstieg okay das alles klingt erstmal
katastrophe europa und du denkst
vielleicht ich würde nun mit einer
hochrechnung kommt wie viel weiter
fortgeschritten und wohlhabende europa
ohne dieses schreckliche blues soul
heute wäre aber weit gefehlt denn der
weitgehenden konsens der historiker über
die langfristigen auswirkungen der
epidemie werden dich vom hocker hauen
der schwarze tod bewirkt und
beschleunigt nämlich einen
tiefgreifenden wandel des sozialen und
kulturellen muster europas in denen der
kontinent seit dem mittelalter festsaß
und langfristig führte der massive
bevölkerungs eindruck seiner durchaus
positiven umstrukturierung der
gesellschaft du fragst dich wie das
gehen soll nun dafür gibt es von der
geschichtsforschung eine sehr fundierte
erklärung da nun weniger arbeitskräfte
zur verfügung standen mussten unrentable
bewirtschaftung 'nen aufgegeben und ein
weitaus größerer prozentsatz der
übertriebenen bevölkerung in die
wertschöpfung einbezogen werden diese
bekamen uns zugang zu eigenem land
musste besser ausgebildet und höher
entlohnt werden diese emanzipation führt
zu mehr selbstbewusstsein und einem
höheren lebensstandard aber auch zu mehr
konflikten zwischen großgrundbesitzern
und arbeitsbevölkerung diese
bauernaufstände führten dann jedoch
schließlich zur abschaffung der
leibeigenschaft und die höheren
arbeitskosten führten auch zu einem
höheren innovationsdruck und zunehmende
mechanisierung und das nicht nur in der
landwirtschaft ein schönes beispiel ist
der buchdruck solange schreiber billig
waren lohnte es sich nicht eine methode
zu finden um sie zu ersetzen erst mit
dem anstieg ihrer lohnkosten fand
johannes gutenberg motivation und
geldgeber um den buchdruck zu entwickeln
und erst mit dem buchdruck wurden die
ersten massenmedien möglich die
voraussetzungen für die reformation und
schließlich aufklärung welche die
europäische gesellschaft erst zu dem
gemacht haben was sie heute ist und wer
weiß vielleicht wären ohne die
europäische pest katastrophe alle diese
gesellschaftlichen und technischen
innovationen zuerst
im nahen osten entstanden dann wäre
heute der islam reformiert und
aufgeklärt das christentum teufelskreis
mittelalter nicht ein stumpfes gefangen
und die industriell kapitalistisch
revolution wäre statt von manchester
vielleicht mekka ausgegangen was meinst
du klingt ihr das zu spekulativ dann
hört er mal an wie epidemien die
geschichte eines anderen kontinents
nachweislich wegweisend geformt haben
die oberen amerikas
[Musik]
so positiv am ende die auswirkungen des
schwarzen todes für europa war
sofern nicht mit und apokalyptisch
wirken sich die von europa nach amerika
eingeschleppten solchen auf die dortige
indigene bevölkerung raus für die
europäischen kolonisatoren waren sie
jedoch der schlüssel zu einer
beispiellosen invasion landnahme und
totalen umformung des amerikanischen
kontinents
tja irgendwie kann ich mich nicht ist
eindrucks erwähnen dass gerade europäer
aus diesem schrecklichen solchen
katastrophen immer als gewinner
hervorgehen so als gäbe es einen
geheimen pakt zwischen diesen
gleichgewichtigen langnasen und den
winzigen mikro was für eine
verschwörungstheorie nun auch wenn du
nichts an diese micro kostenlos zu
bedenken dass die zahl der spanischen
kolonisatoren welche ab 1492 auf dem
amerikanischen kontinent als erste ankam
im vergleich zur bevölkerungszahl der
ureinwohner verschwindend gering war
super super wenn es sich gut sie haben
bessere waffen und pferde aber ihr aller
größter vorteil war ihr durch russisches
solchen gestelltes immunsystem in
verbindung mit all den bakterien und
viren die sie mitbrachten und denen die
ureinwohner amerikas plötzlich wehrlos
ausgesetzt waren und diese mikroben
töteten unglaublich viel mehr von ihnen
als ist alle konquistadoren jemals
vermurt eines der bittersten beispiel
dafür ist die insel hispaniola auf der
sich heute die dominikanische republik
und haiti befinden bevor columbus dort
ankam lebten dort wohl mehrere millionen
menschen
der historiker jared diamond schätzt
dass innerhalb nur weniger jahre die
bevölkerungszahl von ursprünglich acht
millionen auf quasi null gesunken
die insel war plötzlich menschenleer und
dies führte zu einer weiteren
katastrophalen entwicklung dem
startschuss zur einfuhr afrikanischer
sklaven
denn die europäer wollten ja nicht
fruchtbaren würden welche die
einheimische bevölkerung von hispaniola
zurückgelassen hat er nicht fliegen
lassen sondern lukrativ ausbauten
tja dieser europäischen wieder und ihre
krankheiten aber hispaniola ist nur ein
trauriges beispiel unter vielen anderen
1519 landete hernan cortes mit 600
männern an den küsten mexikos um das
abstecken reich in dem mehrere millionen
menschen lebten zu unterjochen
wir kamen im ersten anlauf jedoch eine
herbe abfuhr bei der viele von cortez
mine ums leben kam
beim zweiten versuch erhielt er jedoch
unerwartet hilfe von den pocken als
diese 1520 nach mexiko kamen brachten
sich fast die hälfte der gesamten
städtischen bevölkerung dahin
einschließlich ihres kaisers kutlak die
epidemie war für die azteken aber nicht
du unglaublich mörderisch sondern auch
demoralisierend die spanier von der
krankheit unberührt erschien ihnen nun
fast unbezwingbare gott halten ware
götte response denn die vernichtung
hatte auch hier apokalyptische ausmaße
innerhalb nur eines jahrhunderts sank
die gesamtbevölkerung des aztekenreiches
von fast 20 millionen auf weniger als 2
millionen ein genozid unvorstellbaren
ausmaßes und ein ähnliches schicksal
ereilte auch die in kaarst francisco
pizarro kann im jahr 1531 mit 168
männern an den küsten des heutigen busan
um das inka reich für die spanische
krone zu erobern
und er hatte sofort leichtes spiel denn
die elf jahre zuvor weit im norden
eingeschleppten trocken hatten sich
schon längst bis dorthin durchgefressen
und dabei ganze arbeit geleistet ein
großteil der bevölkerung war an ihnen
gestorben
die einst stolzen und mächtigen in kamen
waren nur noch ein schatten ihrer selbst
und auch kaiserhof eine car pack und
sein direkter thronfolger waren ihnen
erlegen zwischen seinen überlebenden
söhnen brach 1 letzter fleisch oder
erbfolgekrieg aus und pizarro musste mit
seinen 168 männern nur noch zur quasi
schlüsselfertigen übernahme des inka
reichs einmarschieren tja was meinst du
was wäre aus amerika geworden ohne die
biologischen waffen der europäer wäre es
sie zu einem einwanderungsland für
europäer geworden zum schmelztiegel der
welt und zur anschließenden weltmacht
welche den globus heute kulturell
politisch und technologisch trägt jede
weltmacht welche europa schließlich von
der bar bereit der nazis befreien und
von der totalität des sowjetkommunismus
beschützen musste was wäre aus europa
und der ganzen welt geworden ohne jenes
amerika das von solchen entvölkert und
dann durch europäer 9 besiegt wurde
wir wissen es nicht aber ganz sicher
stimmst du mir zu wenn ich sage die welt
wäre eine ganz ganz andere aber lasst
uns nun zunächst
zivilisations prägenden pandemie kommen
[Musik]
die spanische grippe die spanische
grippe eine variante des
influenza-a-virus brach aus als die welt
mit voller geschwindigkeit auf die
moderne zusteuerte schätzungen zufolge
starben während dieser pandemie zwischen
den jahren 1918 und 1919 zwischen 17 und
100 millionen menschen ja erst richtig
gehört zwischen 17 und 100 millionen
und wenn es nicht wundert dass diese
zahl so stark schwankt dann musst du dir
nochmal genauer ansehen wie heute also
und 100 jahre später todesfälle im
zusammenhang mit dem corona diskutiert
werden was wir uns aber auch
vergegenwärtigen müssen ist die tatsache
dass die weltbevölkerung damals nur
circa 1,8 milliarden betrug auf heutige
zahlen hochgerechnet würde dies also 200
bis 430 millionen toten entsprechen also
so was wie der gesamten bevölkerung der
usa
und das klingt schon ziemlich übel
meinst du nicht hinzu kommt dass die
spanische grippe besonders bei jungen
menschen im alter zwischen 20 und 40
jahren endgültig fertig und kleiner fun
fact trotz ihres namens hatte die
spanische grippe in spanien wieder ihren
ursprung noch wütete sie dort besonders
stark ihren namen bekam sie verpasst
weil die zeitungen im damals neutralen
spanien keiner militärzensur unterlagen
und daher als erste über die grippe frei
berichten konnten ihren ursprung hatte
sie wahrscheinlich in us militärlager
während des ersten weltkriegs
unmenschlichen bedingungen in denen
schüssen drehen und starke
truppenbewegungen führten wohl zum
ausbruch und zur ausbreitung dieser
krankheit und als die soldaten am ende
des krieges nach hause zurückkehrten
brachten sie das virus mit insgesamt
dürften sich damals wohl 500 millionen
menschen also jeder dritte auf den
planeten mit ihr angesteckt haben mit
besonders und todesraten in asien und
afrika und bis heute versuchen
wissenschaftler herauszufinden warum
gerade diese krippe sucht ungewöhnlich
verlief warum männer viel stärker
betroffen als frauen
warum die grippe in afrika südlich der
sahara mehr wütete als in europa und den
usa jedoch paradoxerweise europäische
einwanderer stärker betroffen waren als
afrika und wie immer kommt bei den
erklärungsversuchen am ende meist heraus
dass monokausale erklärungsmodelle
welche unterschiede an einzelfaktoren
wie genetik alter oder sozialverhalten
fest zu machen versuchen einfach nicht
funktionieren so nun aber zu den
auswirkungen der
eigentlich sind diese heute ebenso
unklar wie ihre ursachen klar ist nur
dass die unterhaltungs und
dienstleistungsbranche schon damals
herbe verluste zu verzeichnen hatte die
gesundheitsbranche inklusive
pharmaindustrie hingegen gigantische
profite gesellschaftlich waren die
auswirkungen eher negativ die während
oder unmittelbar nach der pandemie
geborene ja diesen generell ein
niedrigeres bildungsniveau und einkommen
und eine höhere rate körperlicher
behinderungen auf als jene die früher
wurde später zur welt kam nun das sind
die harten fakten aber vielleicht
interessieren sich so wenig auch die
alternativ historische gedankenspiele zu
dieser panne ja dann passt jetzt gut
auch der amerikanische
politikwissenschaftler entreißt misst
und der britische forscher haben nämlich
datenmodelle entwickelt welche beweisen
sollen dass die grippewellen deutschland
und seine verbündeten im ersten
weltkriegs stärker geschwächt hätten als
ihre gegner
dadurch hätte sich das kräfteverhältnis
in den letzten kriegstagen stark
umgekehrt und zur niederlage der
achsenmächte geführt und tatsächlich
waren die grippe sterberaten in
deutschland und österreich wesentlich
höher als in großbritannien und
frankreich hätte das deutsche
kaiserreich ohne die spanische grippe
den krieg also gewonnen wäre die welt
ohne diese pandemie heute also eine
deutsche stadt molo amerikanische berlin
das weltfinanzsystem und nicht nur dort
deutsch die globale lingua franca und
mitteleuropa eine vielvölker monarchie
ohne nationalistischen bahn die welt
dominiert von sauerkraut und wir bald
handeln statt big macs und kentucky
fried chicken wäre hitler ohne sein
politisches sprungbrett
dh vertrag in der bedeutungslosigkeit
versuchen hätte sich allerhöchstens als
marktschreier fischverkäufer oder sport
kommentator ausgetobt hätte es keine
chance gegeben dafür aber heute ein
blühendes europäisches juni 2 wer weiß
alles spekulation aber durchaus ein
gedankenspiel wert
die moderne
so liebe freundin dies waren die drei
größten pandemien mit denen die
menschheit im laufe ihrer geschichte
konfrontiert war
im vergleich zu ihnen sind die risiken
und möglichen schäden einer pandemie im
laufe der jahrzehnte aufgrund der
fortschritte in medizin und
pharmakologie wesentlich zurückgegangen
und dennoch wurden wir auch in den
letzten jahrzehnten von ein paar nicht
unwesentlichen gesundheits krisen
heimgesucht das influenza-a-virus schlug
zwischen den jahren 1957 58 als
asiatische grippe zu diese war nach der
spanischen grippe die zweitschlimmste
influenza-pandemie des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts weltweit verstanden damals
zwei millionen menschen in deutschland
rund 30.000 was jedoch im rahmen anderer
schwerer grippe wellen liegt und was
heutzutage sowohl von medien als auch
von der öffentlichkeit vergessen wird
ist dass hiv welches anfang der 80er
jahre plötzlich auftauchte unter den 35
millionen menschen leben gekostet hat
[Musik]
und nein es ist kein schnee von gestern
hiv ist nach wie vor eine der größten
globalen gesundheitlichen bedrohungen
zurzeit schätzungsweise 42 millionen
menschen mit dem virus infiziert
jährlich kommen 1,7 millionen euro und
knapp 700.000 von ihnen sterben an den
folgen der krankheit ja soll ja auch
wenn die wissenschaft im kampf gegen
aids große fortschritte gemacht hat die
zusammen mit prophylaktischen
vorkehrungen ihre sterblichkeitsrate
deutlich gesenkt haben eines tages wird
man auch hiv besiegen können vielleicht
wird man das virus nicht ganz ausrotten
aber es wird für keinen mehr ein
todesurteil darstellen
denn so wie unsere vorfahren durch leben
auch wir ständig eine art krieg gegen
die mikroorganismen den wir gewinnen mit
einem krieg den wir jeden tag gewinnen
und zwar nur damit in unserer nachkommen
und weiterführen können denn viren und
bakterien waren schon lange vor uns da
und werden noch lange lange nach dem
untergang der menschheit auf diesen
planeten weiter existieren denn ihr
funktionsprinzip ist aus evolution nicht
einfach unschlagbar und ihre nische in
der natur von menschen nicht einnehmen
aber das liebe freunde wäre natürlich
schon wieder ein thema sein das andere
video weißt du sind unsere
schlussfolgerungen bezüglich der
geschichtlichen einfluss zu der epidemie
in europa und amerika und der spanischen
grippe plausibel in welche richtung wird
die korona virus pandemie die menschheit
lenken und wo wären wir schon heute ohne
sie bitte schreibt alles was euch dazu
einfällt in den kommentarbereich unter
diesem video
denn wie immer sind wir auf eure
kommentare hochgradig gespannt wir
hoffen dass er dieses video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja es auch einen
daumen hoch und unterstütze uns in dem
duett mit deinen freunden heißt und
vergesst bitte nicht dass nicht jede
woche neue videos hochladen werden also
verpasst keines unserer update abonniert
unseren kanal blickt auch auf das kleine
symbol um rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu
werden macht gut und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]